j moins 3 avant la grève du 5 décembre
les collaborateurs de claques site
prépare cette journée avec leurs
entreprises partenaires objectif
proposer des solutions de covoiturage
aux salariés pour se rendre sur leur
lieu de travail
en cas d'absence de transport en commun
on travaille aujourd'hui avec la région
ile-de-france mobilité qui vient pendant
les grèves apporter une gratuité des
trajets pour les passagers et une
indemnisation pour les conducteurs de 4
euros par passager transporté
clac ci travaille avec une dizaine
d'entreprises à saint quentin en
yvelines en règle générale 30000 trajets
sont proposés chaque jour sur le
territoire
on travaille principalement avec des
entreprises du cac 40
très éclairé principal employeur de la
zone de saint quentin en yvelines pour
créer en fait un réseau de manière à ce
que toutes les entreprises autour puisse
également co voiturer facilement là on
anticipant les grèves on a préparé des
outils de communication spécifique donc
d e-mailing des supports affiches etc de
manière à ce que les entreprises
puissent communiquer directement auprès
leurs salariés cette start up a été créé
en 2013 elle propose des contrats aux
entreprises pour organiser un réseau de
covoiturage
depuis c'est devenu une solution en
période de mobilisation sociale
cette grève n'a pour nous rien avoir en
fait avec celle de 2018
on se rappelle un arrêt 2018 la grève
sncf on le ressent vraiment avec les
différents appels entrants que l'on
aille la tente qu'il y à vraiment autour
des covoiturages que l'on entre dans une
autre dimension pour nous une grève on
va dire qu'ils durent plus longtemps va
permettre justement de pousser plus de
personnes à partager leurs voitures de
passagers à utiliser le covoiturage est
donc un s'inscrire aussi dans la durée
ce jeudi 5 décembre à 8h claque site
enregistré 14 fois plus de réservations
par rapport à la semaine dernière